würd sagen bestes beispiel für einen
hacker / geht einfach nichts kann da ist
entweder eine bestes geben ja er fliegt
herum aber er reicht halt nicht so sechs
kids und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge hacker sowie immer zeige ich
euch heute die drei besten hacker die
mir in der letzten woche eingesendet
wurden
checkt auch mal den link in der
beschreibung ab den allerersten das ist
ein link die schon eine weile drin hatte
über den kommt hier zur registrierung
für eine knochenmarkspende bei der dkms
also wenn ihr 17 jahre oder älter sein
tut mir gefallen checkt den link ab ich
bekomme dafür keine kohle ich mache das
einfach so unterstützt das gerne also
alle 17 jährigen und älter linke der
beschreibung klicken für alle anderen
die gerne was ein schicken wollen gilt
wie immer per youtube pn den link von
dem umgerüsteten video einschicken und
mach bitte keine musik in den
hintergrund
das mache ich selbst so das wasser war
eigentlich schon wir können loslegen mit
der ersten sendung von youtube der sagt
hey cafés jump league extrem witzig er
behauptet es extrem wertvoll sind nicht
nur musik ist er rennt um auch voll ab
da vorne darüber gut red bull getrunken
würde ich sagen
halter dieses bh alter schwede
wie der einfach durch die gegend rennen
okay natürlich gehen wir nie so ein
speed gesehen auf dem ordner [ __ ] alter
was dreht sie 3000 einem kreis
verbrennen diesem moment wenn du deinen
vorherigen leben einfach ein beyblade
fast genau
und noch eine einsendung die stammt von
yoshi heißt fly hacker in jump lily
fragezeichen weil guck mal was ich
abgeht
sobald die flugzeuge bisschen durch die
luft riss orten oktober täglich zwei
schöne kills bzw abgestaubt li na ja
fast alles ja immer ein bisschen komisch
aus wie der unter viel weiß ich
teilweise den eindruck dass der typ
effekt weil er wie sich komisch bewegt
already aber wohl jetzt unser ok alles
klar natürlich natürlich momentan muss
jetzt mal kurz ermittelt extra das los
warum ist jetzt der spieler da oben das
war genau genau der player der gerade
eben gefallen ist wie gesagt ein
bisschen komisch aus man sieht ziemlich
wirklich daran wie die spieler sich
bewegen
sag ich bisher sehr komisch aus also die
jetzt in freiheit selber wenn sie da
oben ist gerne komm runter jetzt macht
der from heaven macht den klassischen
stairway bündelt gut galt da ist so
peinlich peinlich fühlt er sich jetzt
wieder zu hause sitzt und leute zu ihm
hoch schauen oder gesunder gekommen ist
das natürlich nicht gefilmt so aber so
für kinder haben nicht gereicht bei ihm
ja wahrscheinlich würde jetzt zerstört
nein er fliegt hoch
er kommt sogar noch wegmann
ist einfach ne pause rey er hat noch ein
leben darum jetzt kommen runter ohne
sturmowski am start
da kommt darunter keinen fall schaden
erleidet irgendwie runter und jetzt ja
okay jetzt verabschiedet hoffentlich
sachsen hinweg
kommt jungs packt leichte schieflage
woran liegt sich kann sich begründen bin
erstmal auf k geht an escape schreibt
sogar in den chats oder so muss das voll
cool bietet 100 mit dem fall ist so toll
und das ist übrigens fast wie
tontaubenschießen wenn seiner freiheit
hat man hält mit dem bogen braucht es
sieht für mich sowie einer aus der auch
einfach nur einen account hat und der
dann wirklich einfach perma gewand ist
und nicht mehr minecraft spielen kann
so wird er sich verhält ja es ist er gut
mein sohn ist ja gut kommt deshalb bei
dir nicht mehr für köhler gereicht das
ist okay aber dann spielen einfach spiel
einfach okay heute aggressiv walter ich
muss vorsprung nichts vorspielen das
geht mir zu sagt ich will sehen wie es
ausgeht so vorgespult die ohne oder von
10 sekunden
sie stehen im spot sieht geil aus alter
von unter 3 bitte lasst bitte lass ihn
verlieren bitte lass ihn verlieren und
verloren
der mail von ihm aufnehmen land gewonnen
sehr gut
ok nächste einem stamm von shooter 885
oder schickt ein video namens hacker
show escape aufkommen möchte dann hacker
aufkomme german gut schon rein kurz mal
checken wirklich german ist ja das war
auf jeden fall in german schnaufer das
sagen ob ich noch besser ausfiel
also es ist besser selbst
ich bin einfach nur paranoid geworden
okay aber selbst mit noch mehr kriegt
der typ ist einfach nicht hin
irgendwas zu reißen selbst mit noch
gekriegt einfach nichts gebacken
du musst denken bestattung in deinem
leben
das achte mal darauf die ziele aktiviert
er gleich mal ins dem flyer alles klar
beziehungsweise geleit und sprint durch
die luft in richtung wetter auch nicht
schlecht so jetzt hinterher
schnapp dir jetzt abgelaufen
man macht einfach nicht jetzt fliegt
noch hoch du hast trotzdem von nichts
reißen trotz seiner ex was macht ihr da
des schlechter sicht im bett wars
super essen laura draußen vorbei und da
fragt man also das ist vielleicht der
schlechteste hacker den ich jemals
gesehen habe
ja es gibt einfach keinen fall mehr
aber es trotzdem so grottenschlecht wenn
ich das könnte was er da könnte aber die
ganze drum fliegen ja und er macht
weiter mit
ja alles klar elevator nach oben leute
leute leute leute da sieht man wieder
die glide heck wir so langsam runter
geleitet wird sagen bestes beispiel für
einen hacker / kita ein paar nichts kann
das entweder bases geben ja er fliegt
rum aber er reicht halt nichts dann wird
er wieder zurück vom chip es ist einfach
erbärmlich so das ist wirklich einfach
schlecht gespielt hat wirklich
vielleicht so ziemlich alle hacks
aktivierte aktivieren kann gerade eben
frei heck das war heftig los dann
gleitet katrin hat er auf die folklore
hat auf jeden fall noch becker hat
diesen komischen heck der einen zurück
auf ein steak teleportiert zurück auf
die blöcke teleportiert mettwurst wie es
die eigentlich das können meine
kommentare schreiben der genau hier
auftaucht hat seiner männer mit seinen
ganzen häcksler doch geschafft unseren
play hier zu töten und zwar hier
da fliegt der anderen ob beck und unser
player herunter rip in pepperoni ich hab
das muss man gar nicht mehr sagen es ist
einfach ganz klarer fall das war es
soweit von der heutigen folge hacker
schon brenzlig gefallen hat wie immer
gerne daumen da lassen wenn ihr was
einsenden volt per youtube en
denkt dran video auf ungelöste nicht auf
privat mindestens in 720p und s16 zu
neuen firma hat das ist ganz wichtig
also keine schwarzen balken oben unten
in der mitte oder schrecken versetzt
weil das macht einfach nicht so schön
anzuschauen und wir wollen ja dass man
sich schön anschauen kann
gut dass wir bis ins bei der nächsten
folge wieder aufholen
euro